hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast validation and
commercialization of liquid biopsy in a
CLIA lab I'm Christina Joel of lab works
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational seminars presented
by labrys the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the side
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left
I would now like to introduce today's
speaker mr. Michael Nam Michael mall has
over 25 years of healthcare sales and
marketing experience most recently
serving at Clarion diagnostic services
incorporated in positions of increasing
responsibility from 2002 through August
2013 with his last position being
general manager in North American sales
and marketing while at Clarion mr. null
was also responsible for leading the
team assimilating Clarion into GE
healthcare after Clarion was acquired in
2010 from 1988 until joining Clarion mr.
Nobbs served in the diagnostic and
medical device industries in various
commercial leadership roles for
companies including impact American
Cyanamid Mackay surgical shraddha
medical horizon medical products and
Colombia vital systems mr. Hall received
a Bachelor of Science degree in business
administration from Central Missouri
State University now known as the
University of Central Missouri I will
now turn it over to
Sternoff for his presentation mr. nam
darby folks I'm excited to be here and
shared the story of bio separate ility
personalized medicine through a liquid
biopsy and before I get started I always
take a couple minutes to explain to
folks what do we mean by this liquid
biopsy concept as if you google it
you're going to get a lot of hits well a
bio suck
we help patients who have been diagnosed
with cancer make sure that they get the
most appropriate treatment by their
physicians so their physicians send us a
simple blood draw and we can get
personalized medicine information from
that blood draw that they use to make
treatment decisions for their patients
so a little bit about our company a bio
SEP well we have 18 patents on the
testing that we do we're focused on two
aspects to the tuba blood that comes in
they're circulating tumor cells which
are intact cells that are shed from
solid tumors into the bloodstream
provide a source that we do specific
genomic proteomic analysis as well as
cell free circulating tumor DNA so all
the cells in your body are breaking down
constantly and when they do so they
release nucleic acid into your
bloodstream cancer cells are the same
way so we can isolate those rare cancer
DNA fragments out of the blood and
analyze those on the genomic basis so
really two areas we look at both with
patented technology intact cells called
circulating tumor cells as well as cell
free circulating tumor DNA we provide
this information that physicians used to
make treatment decisions for the
patients to make sure they get on the
most appropriate care get the most
appropriate care that they can we do
this testing in our laboratory it's
called a CLIA lab which stands for
clinical lab Improvement Act and its cap
accredited as well the College of
American Pathologists so high quality
results that come out of our lab as they
inspect us every other year to make sure
we meet these stringent quality
standards
now our labs located right here in San
Diego we get specimens that extend from
all over the world and we do the testing
right here but in the future we want to
go through the FDA so we can then market
our testing to be done at hospital labs
and labs all around the world so that's
in the future of bio so now we've grown
very
this liquid biopsy is addressing a true
and medical need for patients and we'll
talk more about that at that but our
volumes have grown as our revenues have
grown as well and we've done that with a
lot of collaborations we aren't doing it
alone we have world-class institutions
that we collaborate with with various
different studies from the University of
California San Diego Moores Cancer
Center right here to Georgetown Indiana
Sun dana-farber many others that we
either have active or have had
collaborations and research studies with
so this is a very large market and I'm
on slide number terior this is a very
large market that's estimated to be
between 10 and 20 billion dollars by the
big banks you know goldman sachs UBS
Bank of America JP Morgan they all have
analyst reports just in liquid biopsy
and they say it's going to be very big
and that's because you're taking testing
that's normally done one time only for a
patient maybe two times with a biopsy
surgical procedure and we can deliver
that same information with a simple
blood draw and the key is the blood draw
can be done over and over and over to
monitor the patient so that's one of the
biggest advantages of using blood versus
a surgical biopsy you know a physician
isn't going to turn their patients into
a pin cushion and biopsy them over and
over this is a blood test you can test
that patient every time they come to
their physician now we do we focus on
the most clinically actionable
information so in other words we say
it's the biomarkers the biomarkers are
the genomic signatures that you look for
to see what therapies a patient could
possibly qualify for so examples are
her2 and you could qualify for Herceptin
from Genentech EGFR could qualify you
EGFR mutation could qualify you for
Tarceva from Genentech alq
translocation could qualify you for
Xalkori from Pfizer etc so there's a
whole bunch of these different what we
call targeted therapies you need to know
this personalized biomarker information
this is what we test the CT sees this is
the intact circulating tumor cells as
well as the cell-free circulating tumor
DNA for now we do this in a very
specific and sensitive format with our
proprietary impact
technology's so industry-leading
sensitivity and specificity and the
testing we provide of course this is
leading to high growth oncologists need
this information and they like they like
the way we deliver it focused on these
markers that they know what to do it now
because we are able to develop these
assays and perform them in our own lab
we can really drive costs down and
actually someday have a margin as we get
to scale at the business that we do
right here in the laboratory this
creates a lot of opportunities for value
creating partnerships both here in the
US and outside the US many of the
patents we have are in other countries
such as China Korea the EU even
Australia so a lot of opportunities to
create more and more partnerships
outside the US and as we said earlier we
want to admit move this to a format
where hospitals all around the world can
do it so just to make it clear what
we're able to do at bio Sept is take
what normally requires a surgical tissue
biopsy to get the first lines molecular
information that's needed for treatment
decisions all from a simple blood draw
that's what you see illustrated here as
well as a sample of the report that goes
back to the physician who order in our
chest and they use that to make
treatment decisions for their patients
so why would someone here it's a liquid
biopsy a BioSense which is a simple
blood test well first of all many
patients are to 6 so we're truly
addressing an unmet medical need for
those patients those patients could be
too sick to even undergo a surgical
biopsy so in that case a liquid biopsy
is able to provide the information but
simply not available if the biopsy can't
be performed so that's a true unmet
medical need we're addressing in
addition even if the biopsy is performed
today especially in lung cancer many
times its time with what's called a fine
needle aspirate in other words a very
small needle biopsy that's then used for
not just the molecular testing but also
to make the diagnosis so very often
there isn't enough tissue available in
lung cancer to actually give the
information so also true when other
cancers become metastatic so or spread
there's very often just not enough
tissue to get the information that they
need to make the treatment decision we
address that unmet medical need
providing that information from a simple
blood test
if a patient has metastatic disease to
the bone it's very difficult in a biopsy
and if so very often can't be counted on
because you can't trust a negative
result due to the processing of that
bone specimen to do the testing so we
can help there as well and finally
there's a concept of heterogeneity both
intra tumor heterogeneity as well as
inner tumor discordance
and really those just mean differences
between either the biopsy itself as we
look at different parts of the biopsy or
within different sites of that
metastatic disease for instance if
there's bone and brain net might have
different knowledge signature so with a
blood sample we're getting Brigantine
cells and DNA shed from all over that
tumor and therefore we account for that
heterogeneity with what we see in the
blood the easiest way to understand that
is to picture a loaf of raisin bread and
so if you had a loaf of raisin bread and
you put a needle in you might hit a
raisin you might not so that's the same
with the tumor there's a lot of
heterogeneity within a tumor so as the
physician does the biopsy they could be
missing important drivers that would be
in a different part of the tumor that
wasn't available to them so with the
blood test we hope to address for that
but one of the most important advantages
that a liquid biopsy has over tissue
biopsies cost even with our testing a
liquid biopsy cost about $1,300 and
that's on average with what Medicare or
the private payers will pay us a tissue
biopsy in America can cost up to 60
there's in a lung biopsy and that's when
everything goes right it's not just the
surgery charges it's the hospital
charges pharmacy pathology radiology if
you've ever had a procedure you know
that it all adds up with a liquid biopsy
leave the opportunity to save huge
amount of money for the healthcare
system which is so important in this day
of the age of healthcare cost
constraints so this is a big potential
market we know of it's based on both
profiling and monitoring for liquid
biopsy and we all know folks who are
afflicted with cancer and as we know
there's there's more and more diagnosed
every year as the baby boomers come into
their later stage of life
so today am i OSA
and I'm on slide six by the way we're
looking at several aspects to this large
market first one is profiling that's
where most of the specimens that we get
in today or in the profiling area and
that's where we help get an answer for
patients when they're newly diagnosed or
when their tumor occurs we also are
starting to get a lot more business for
monitoring monitoring for signs of
progression of disease or response to
therapy we hope and they can do that
because the tumor cells and the tumor da
in the blood are tied to the tumor
themselves so if the tumor themselves is
going away therefore you would expect
that there's not too much those into a
DNA in the blood that are persistent so
that's an important aspect well finally
companion diagnostics as well is
something that we're doing a bio simple
involved with two pharma trials today
where we developed assays early stage
drugs as they start to explore the
impact of their treatment successful
that puts us in a good position but the
assays would develop for them and
potential licensing opportunity as they
move their drugs through the regulatory
path finally they're screening and today
we are in a screening of BIOS up but
that's an opportunity in the future I
think opportunity for screening but a
lot more data needs to be gathered with
screening um as we find out what it
would mean if we found small amounts of
DNA or circulating tumor cells not
otherwise asymptomatic patients so in
other words if your I would have an
annual test to find out if we might have
cancer in our blood sounds like common
sense but in reality at this point as an
industry we don't know what to do with
that if we found it because your immune
system might take care of it or toy
surgery full-body scans so screenings in
the future for everybody in liquid
biopsy today we're focused on profiling
monitoring and companion diagnostics so
at my own said we're the premier
commercial platform the liquid biopsy
and that's because we've got this patent
protection around what we do very high
performance with the validations both in
sensitivity and specificity of our
testing very strong growth delivered by
our world-class commercial team getting
paid more and more every day as we gain
more and more contracts recently just
came to contract with one of the Blues
plans very happy about that
and
additionally an opportunity to drive
costs down out of the systems and keep
our cost with what the payers are
willing to pay for this testing and
finally in some day in the future we'll
be looking at as kits that we can then
market to hospitals and labs all around
the world and let them do the same
testing we do in our blood today so when
you see the next slide you can see it
looks kind of like a tree but it's
actually a great diagram that came out
of nature that shows your circulatory
system and so I love this diagram when
we do these talks because it helps to
indicate what we're actually analyzing
you know in a cartoon fashion so you can
see over on the left side of the screen
there are the left side the image
there's a mass and that's the blue part
that's shedding DNA as you can see there
cell-free DNA as well as towards the top
an intact cell a circulating tumor cell
these are both important to capture and
analyze because they both have unique
things you can get out of them so with
the circulating tumor cells we can get
protein expression we can get DNA
amplification these are all tests that
require the context of an intact cell so
that's important from the same tube of
blood we get both intact cells the
circulating tumor cells as well as that
cell free DNA which you can get out of
the plasma and that's what you see down
below and you can get mutations and copy
number out of that all important
information for a patient and all needed
by that position to make a treatment
decision so when a tumor blood comes in
to bio Sept we spin it down into its
components you have the plasma on top of
that spun down blood and we do the
mutations from there so that's where we
get our use our fragments the
circulating tumor DNA in the middle of
the components you have what's called
the Buffy coat and this is where the
nucleated cells land because when you go
through centrifugation with a blood
sample the light part of the blood goes
to the top and the heavier part the red
cells with the iron goes to the bottom
in the middle the nucleated cells this
is where the circulating tumor cells are
primarily it's white blood cells the
normal cells so maybe a million white
blood cells and yet only ten to a
hundred tumor cells how do we get that
into a 100 tumor cells up that's where
we're a proprietary and patented
technology
comes in so first though let's take a
look at what we do with plasma and by
the way when I mentioned the patents the
patents go away from the vacutainer tube
we use to collect the blood and it's got
our media inside and that media keeps
the specimen viable for up to 96 hours
for circulating tumor cells to eight
days for circulating tumor DNA so that
allows us to get specimens not just from
here in the US but from all over the
world through customs so we can then do
the testing in our lab here in San Diego
UC next is our microfluidic Channel
that's the size of a microscope slide
it's clear just like a slide that
purplish color you see inside his die so
you can see the fluid path but that's
how we capture the intact cells we also
then stain them and identify them so we
can know what they are once they're in
there and some of that is patented as
well and finally our cell-free process
has patents pending now with the
cell-free process it works in a very
elegant way to totally suppress the
normal DNA so an easy way to understand
that when you're looking at DNA
fragments in your blood is that all the
cells in your body are constantly
growing and dividing and dying and
breaking down when they do they release
all the DNA and nucleic acid into your
bloodstream now when we isolate that DNA
there's vastly more normal DNA called
wild-type that's what you see the WT
they're wild-type is your normal DNA it
has a lot more of that than it does with
the cancer mutation mutated DNA that
we're looking for so in other words we
have a classic needle and the haystack
scenario so the way that our platform
works it's a chemistry that actually
suppresses the normal DNA and only
allows amplification in other words
detection of the mutations that we're
looking for in a certain region of the
DNA so in other words if you picture it
like a switch the switch is off on the
normal or wild-type DNA and the switch
opens up and allows amplification on the
mutations that we identify so very high
sensitivity very high specificity
greater than 99 percent 95 percent
sensitivity 99 percent specificity and
in fact that's at one in 10,000
so in other words one mutation DNA in
10,000 normal so very high sensitive
sensitivity in our assay Witek when it
comes to the intact cells the
circulating tumor cells it works in
another very sensitive and specific way
so once again the plasma in this diagram
has gone off to molecular lab and that's
where we're doing the mutations through
the process that I just described
now with our secondary process for the
intact cell we take that buffy coat and
we mix it with an antibody cuttable
'extra those antibodies latch on to the
tumour cells and those antibodies then
are run through our microfluidic channel
we can then isolate the cancer cells
that have the antibodies on them within
the channel and then the normal cells in
other words the white blood cells that
were not interested in analyzing because
they're not tied to the tumor go on
through so therefore we're left with in
the channel with an enriched population
of tumor cells so from there we stain
them just like you would with the tissue
biopsy that would be done and you can
see examples of the stains that we would
use there's a lot of different stains we
can use on those tumor cells there's two
one would be for protein and you can see
that's the green cell that you see with
the protein expression on the outside of
the cell or the membrane finding the
next one is the fish testing we do and
you can see this one happens to be for
her too and there's it shows that it is
a cancer cell it's amplified it that
patient where that actual cell came from
would be eligible or receptive therapy
so two different ways we can analyze
them both for protein as well as for
genes all and the channel now we can
also release the cells if you want to do
further analysis on those by advanced
testing called next-gen sequencing now
when I talked about the industry-leading
assay performance there's really two
ways to look at that we always make sure
that we explain this to folks because in
our industry there's two different areas
there's analytic validation which is a
controlled validation that you do with
an unknown a challenge so in other words
you know what went in so you know how
good you are detecting it coming out the
other side so in our case we take two
cells or tumor DNA we spiked it into
normal donor blood in other words blood
that we get from people that don't have
cancer so therefore we know how many
tumor cells went in therefore we know
our efficiency our sensitivity our
specificity at capturing those tumor
cells the same with to our DNA you can
take what's called cell lines and put
them in that blood and then you know how
well you are capturing you can see that
we've done thousands of different
challenges in our analytic validation
and have very high sensitivity and very
high specificity but what most people
ask about when they ask about
sensitivity and specificity is how do
you compare to the standard of care
which is the tissue biopsy so that's a
lot more difficult of a challenge and
that's because the tissue biopsy from a
certain patient is blood we would this
would be a cancer patient could have
been gotten months or even a year
beforehand before the blood comes to us
so therefore as the patient's treated it
becomes their molecular profile the way
we're comparing blood comes different
due to response to therapy and evolution
of disease so even with that we have
very high concordance with the tissue
biopsy at 87% and that's the oncologist
feel very confident in ordering our
tests because of that when we explain it
that way so the generally though the
closer we get to having the blood and
the tissue biopsy at the same time
you'll see the higher the concordance
effect we have one study that was just
presented at the European Society for
medical oncology that we did with
AstraZeneca and with the NIH in Mexico
where we showed 90 percent concordance
in lung cancer with the testing that we
did so the closer we get to the surgical
biopsy and the blood drawn at the same
time the higher you'll see the
concordance in general and then when we
see the further apart you'll see
differences either way still very high
concordance rates with our testing and
tissue so there are other companies that
are also out doing local biopsy and
actually we all kind of support each
other as we all have kind of our own
area that we're playing in with us or
since we're focused on both intact cells
and cell-free DNA that's a truly
differentiator we're also focused on the
biomarkers that most of the other folks
that you see there are focused on very
large panels where
doing a lot of different mutations and
those are really appropriate for
patients where they don't know what else
to do or they're trying to get a patient
in a clinical trial our testing is done
just like they use the surgical tissue
biopsy you get the biomarkers that would
be the kind of the standard treatment
for them so that's that that in other
words and our testing can also be
ordered in an ala carte format so
physicians can order our chests for the
biomarkers they're most interested in
and I have to only get a whole panel so
we have assays that fit a patient don't
try to make our one assay that all
patients so that's kind of how we
differentiate between the others in
addition there's 13 biomarkers that we
validated and what color CLIA lab we can
do more and more biomarkers than that
performance and research projects but
today there's 13 that are available you
see those in the red and you see some of
the other markers we're going to be
launching throughout 2017 in our
pipeline and one of the key things is an
oncologist as I mentioned earlier can
order one biomarker or they can order
multiple biomarkers from this mean so
when they do order a biomarker I always
take a minute to explain how we get paid
and the way we get paid is that each one
of these biomarkers has their own
reimbursement code so in other words
there's a CPT code for EGFR there's a
CPT code for ARS etcetera so it ranges
from about three to four hundred dollars
for each biomarker up to if they order
all of the biomarkers in long it could
be twenty five hundred dollars at
particular rates so it just varies on
what they order as to what the
reimbursement would be but on average
it's about twelve hundred dollars the
patient sample at Medicare rates for
those cases that come through our door
as I mentioned we do have a lot of
partnerships out there we currently are
involved in about 24 research studies
with various folks many really luminary
institutions recently announced a
project we're doing in breast cancer
with Columbia which was key so we are
always presenting at different medical
meetings in symposia we have a lot of
great scientific and clinical advisors
very proud about those folks that we've
been able to get recruited over to help
our company as well as you know also
doing something that was new to me when
I came to bio septon
an important aspect I think for a
marketing plan and that's really working
closely with patient advocacy groups and
if you asked me a few years ago what I
thought the role of patient advocacy
would be I would have said well it's
primarily to support the patient and
that of course is a huge role they play
and very important role but that's not
the only one in fact they're very
involved today with diagnostic companies
with pharma companies making sure
patients are getting those to
appropriate treatment finding patients
for clinical trials funding studies so
when they're involved with various
patient advocacy from you know the lung
cancer foundation of America to breast
cancer groups to they during a lung
cancer foundation so those are important
part of our strategy so we can make sure
our testing becomes aware to more and
more patients and most importantly their
physicians so in addition there's a lot
of data that we've gotten out on our
testing both in publications as well as
abstracts and posters as I said we have
so many different studies and a lot of
the data is now coming out that most of
the big meetings will have either an
abstract poster or a presentation tied
into that meeting I mentioned the most
recent one we had which was with the
European society of medical oncology
showed a 90 percent correlation in
addition we showed 100% analytics
sensitivity and specificity with our PDL
one assay that we presented at world
long at PDL one of course a very
important biomarker today helped to
indicate whether someone will will
qualify for immunotherapy
such as that former with Kate ruda so I
mentioned before about some of the
differences sometimes you can see
between tissue and blood and that's
important to understand you can see that
right here in a real world case study
and this is with one of our
collaborators dr. Bosman OVA at
University of California San Diego
Morris Cancer Center dr. Bosman OA is
fantastic on college she's actually on
the the NCCN guidelines committee for
lung and she was helping us with our
validation with our cell free essay or a
certain biomarker called t79 a.m. which
is part of the EGFR gene and indicates
when you become resistance to therapies
such as Tarceva and she was sending
tissue biopsies to another large
reference lab
send down she was singing blood well it
was missed but the tissue biopsy and I
believe in the log reference lab they
have great testing I think was probably
due to that heterogeneity if you
remember the Raisin Bran analogy when
you might miss something just with a
single biopsy we picked it up with the
blood and so therefore he did something
you would normally not do except if
you're in a teaching hospital like dr.
Boz know is shiri biopsy this at the
second time and sure enough when they
read my I've seen the Almaty seminar so
the blood test was able to detect this
before the tissue biopsy was or we don't
really know but could have been at the
tissue biopsy missed so important aspect
of why you want to do the blood testing
along with the tissue biopsy in order to
qualify patients for these therapies
that truly can say extend their life so
now if you know the oncology market you
know it's a very large market and with a
lot of oncologists in America I've seen
a lot of consolidation and today you
know we're focused on very various
aspects to the business we started out
with the Kol sand I think that's one
thing we did well I hired a sales team
that had experience and a lot of
relationships are easily done in front
of key opinion leaders with our testing
so they would at least know about that's
important because of the community
oncologist wants to call off their
mentor but the teaching hospital we want
them to know about bio so so even if
they don't use this and a lot do they'll
at least hopefully have a good
impression of our company and the
testing we offer from there though we're
starting now to market more and more
kind of at tier two and Tier three where
the patients are treated so most of the
treatment in America is actually given
in the community and will be influenced
though by those tier one medical centers
so today we have salespeople where you
see the red stars all around the country
that eleven sales folks out today and
wanting to grow that as we go throughout
2017
you market to medical oncologists
medical oncologists star the physicians
that actually give the chemotherapy and
the treatments and since this is blood
they can draw the blood right in their
office and sent us so it's an efficient
way we're able to get the information
straight to those who need it the most
the medical oncologists they can feed
their patients in addition we also work
with pathologists in surgical oncology
at time most of the volume that comes
through our door comes from medical
oncology
we also partner with farm and as I said
we've got three Palmer projects right
now that we're working on as a company
they're experienced sales team with
greater than five years experience we
also have an internal staff to support
them in customer service and marketing
and administration now you can see
they're doing a great job we've really
grown over the past year and you can see
that last year we had about 26%
compounded quarterly sequential growth
order or a quarter and when you look at
this slide you can see that the blue is
billable cases these are cases we get
from sessions and they use that to make
treatment decisions give us the milling
information for that patient the rate
each color is what we get from Pharma
and the green are the studies weren't we
don't get paid but those are volume
coming through our lab now one other
thing the health plans like about us is
the fact that we're focused on these
biomarkers that matter so therefore an
oncologist can order just what's most
needed for that patient without having
to order an expensive large panel like
some of the other folks in liquid biopsy
only offer so that's led to a lot of
contracts and in fact as I said we just
announced another agreement across of
Texas earlier you can see that's driving
our revenue growth because we've done
our billing processes worked out our
contracting work out that's paying off
in the revenues that we're gaining as a
company you can see we're growing
quarter-over-quarter there just had our
first million dollar quarter in our last
publicly reported quarter back in q3 of
2016 so we'll be reporting our q4
results probably in the first week
second week of March somewhere in that
time frame so you know as I said today
we're a central lab the test is all done
here in our CLIA lab right here in San
Diego and we want to eventually go
through the FDA and be able to market
our testing so it can be done in
hospitals all around the world today we
can do testing in our own lab know
what's called ldt we do it as an LD T
lab develop test and that's commonplace
in the industry much of the laboratory
and specialty testing that's done in
America today is done through that LTT
format we do tho want to do a new aspect
to it with a partnership model right
here in stage two which we're planning
to launch
this year so that's where we would be
able to allow the hospitals to share in
some of the revenue with the testing we
provide in 2017 as we move more and more
towards the kit strategy in 2019 so
milestones to look or in our company is
continued commercial growth you know
entered in more and more partnerships
signed more health plan agreements well
have more and more data coming out
remember we're involved in 24 different
studies today on traditional markers
which drives our growth and then we'll
also be launching a study that helps to
value capture of this cells that helps
to make our kit strategy in the future a
reality so folks thanks a lot for
listening to our presentation today
about bio SEP I'm happy now to answer
questions about the information that I
present it thank you mr. Noor for that
informative presentation now before we
get started on the question-and-answer
session I just want to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit the questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to get to as many questions as
we can
and if not we'll mr. Nam will be able to
answer those via email post presentation
okay now our first question is mr. Nam
are the BIOS set target selector
offerings used for cancer screening or
monitoring
well thank you Christina that's a good
question so as we talked about earlier
you know there's different aspects to
liquid biopsy today and today meiosis
focused on profiling primarily which is
where we're able to help or a tissue
biopsy is either inadequate or
impossible to get so in other words
there's not enough tissue or the patient
stitute just too sick to even have a
biopsy so we're able to get that
information to an oncologist that they
need to find out how to treat that
patient next we're doing monitoring so
that was one of the things that was
asked is about monitoring and so that's
an area that's really glowing for us
because positions need to look to see is
the patient responding to the therapy or
not and with a molecular test a blood
test that we can do we can start to
monitor that patient every time that the
oncologist sees them so we're really in
profiling and monitoring primarily
screening will be something we're
interested in in the future but there's
a lot more data that the whole industry
has to gather to find out what this
would mean if we can find material in
your blood that would indicate you may
or may not have cancer
so a lot more work to do for a screening
assay in blood today but today we're
focused on profiling and monitoring
primarily
okay next question what is the strategy
around FDA clearance of the assays or is
it even needed oh that's a good question
as well because I know it's a confusing
topic if anybody actually knows about
our area of laboratory medicine there's
been a lot of talk over the past few
years about this idea of lab developed
test LD T's if you google it you're
going to get a lot of information but
today you know most of the laboratory
testing that's done at the molecular
level is done as LD T's in America and
some of the most well known assays such
as Oncotype DX or the Foundation 1rl DTS
so the FDA does not currently regulate
that part of our business that doesn't
mean that there aren't important
validations are done in order to offer a
test in America you need to do an
analytic validation that we described
earlier and then most high quality labs
will go ahead and do clinical
validations as well so you have both
those aspects to be able to meet the
threshold to offer a test for patient
care in the future though we want to go
through the FDA to be able to then take
the testing we do in our own lab and
market that to hospital so that's the
difference I can actually do the testing
in my lab as an LD T today under CLIA
and the cap accreditation that we have
but then for us to take the tests we do
make it into kits and then be able to
market it for specific use we'll need to
go through the FDA and that's something
we want to do in the future
thanks mr. no need some great questions
coming in but we're almost out of time
what's that one more in here how about
this one why is it important to detect
and analyze both cells and DNA fragments
oh I love that question because that's
one of the key differentiators of bio
cept the ability to be able to look at
the intact cells called circulating
tumor cells as well as self research
leading to more DNA all out of that same
standard blood sample so that's
important because there is information
you can only get out of the cell that
you simply can't get out of cell free
DNA so it's just biologically impossible
so we can do protein expression we can
do DNA amplifications these are just
different tests that you need to get
result on so an oncologist knows how to
treat their patient so we go see a
medical oncologist very often they don't
necessarily care that we can do ctcs and
cell-free DNA what they love is that
they can get a protein marker such as ER
for breast cancer and hurt you from
breast cancer at the same time they can
get a mutation as well so in lung cancer
they can get PDL one and they can also
get Alka and Russ one and EGFR mutation
so in other words we can offer a more
comprehensive menu because we can get
tests that can only be done in the cells
and cell-free DNA out of that same blood
job that's very important for their
treatment planning and they're allowing
us that allows us then to be used as a
true surrogate for that tissue biopsy
thank you and as a reminder to our items
if we didn't get a chance to get to your
question it will be answered via email
afterwards mr. Mel do you have any final
comments for our audience
well thank you all for the time together
today enjoyed sharing our story of bio
cept or word Alinea personalized
medicine from a liquid biopsy you know
just a couple things to remember we're
doing our testing today in San Diego and
a CLIA lab and we were able to help
thousands of patients this way more and
more we are getting paid for the work
we're doing which is an important thing
but the most important thing we do every
day is be able to qualify more patience
for these targeted therapies that truly
do extend and save their life so that is
the most important thing thank you very
much a big thank you again mr. Michael
no I would also like to thank our
sponsor lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible now today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 23rd 2017 you will
receive an email from laberd's alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to format that
announcement to your colleagues so may
have missed today's mighty bench thanks
so much for joining us and we hope to
see you next time goodbye